hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wie heute zu einem neuen
video von mir sehe dass bereits im titel
eingeladen meine damen und herren wir
machen heute mal wieder eine von
challenger das bin ich menschlich sind
sämtlich abstoßen und zwar wird es heute
eine challenge seine freunde die nicht
in irgendeiner form in game stattfindet
oder allgemein gegen was mit dem spiel
zu tun sondern ich werde mir schnee
handschuhe anziehen und dabei versuchen
zu spielen
also ich denke mal das schwierigste wird
sein irgendwie die maus vernünftig
festzuhalten weil diese teile sind halt
echt das sind richtig fette handschuhe
ich würde sagen ich springe auf keinen
fall als erstes raus auf kleinsten ich
glaube ich spreche als letztes rache ist
also mal schauen wo der bus lang fliegt
wenn wie ich brauchte gerade fünf
anläufe um das m zu drücken ich glaube
ich bin jetzt einfach mal raus
jetzt müssen wir ihn demnach das weh ich
weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht wo wir
hinfliegen soll ich finde jetzt einfach
mal nach vorne irgendwo ich habe zwar
keiner das ist riesig groß klobig oder
ich sehe schon wieder kommen freunde
richtig bescheuerte runde
ich spiele gerade in meiner linken hand
irgendwie so damit ich die tasten treffe
ach du heilige scheiße nein einkommen
degas das ist doch nicht entscheidend
sei jetzt schon eine waffe oder ja
kommen schließt auf mich okay das cool
so kommen jetzt hier mal eben schnell
rein in die e drücken ja männer den
sniper ja die das machen jetzt natürlich
sinn also ich weiß nicht wo der typ ist
oder wo er sich versteckt hatte ich
würde mich am liebsten immer so ein
bisschen vernünftig raum bewegen aber
ich muss egal
läuft doch schießt doch
oh mein gott wenn doch nicht tot ist
davon hey das ist unmöglich mit diesen
teil zu ziehen ich hoffe ihr vertraut
mir einfach dass diese handschuhe
nebenan habe weil das ding jetzt so wenn
man wenig dieter auf den tasten drauf
bin dann ist es okay
die bin ich denn jetzt den bau modus
gekommen mein job
die sache ist nur wenn ich wechseln
möchte von wa und dann halt nach links
laufen möchte sondern kann schon mal
sein dass ich das drücke und nach hinten
laufen springen jetzt einfach mal hier
raus mal schauen wo wir hingehen ich
würde sagen wir gehen einfach runter das
wird schon irgendwie hinhauen tönen hier
vorne bei der brücke landen hier vorne
haben wir da oben eine kiste werde ich
gehen wir hier oben
ich habe nicht mal holz wie so gehe ich
dann in den bau modus gurtner in fehler
soll hier oben haben wir nicht sagen wir
nur verbände das ist natürlich
wundervoll
das freut mich immer mega hier vorne ist
eine kiste was haben wir da drin haben
wir wieder ein jagdgewehr okay das geht
ja sogar noch ich dachte etwas wenn hier
wieder in das nahe gewesen oder irgend
so ein scheiß weil damit werde ich
wieder richtig gut klargekommen mit den
handschuhen ohne wo ich jetzt gerade
dabei bin
hättet ihr mal bock drauf ich weiß ich
das schon mal gefragt aber live
streaming mäßig ich weiß ich bin nicht
der beste fordert spieler aber mir macht
das spiel spaß ist es genauso wie
minecraft früher da war ich auch der
beschissen sda beim jetzt trotzdem spaß
gemacht und ich hatte bock ist krank es
ist halt echt gerade so dass ich bin mir
genau die tasten hier angucken muss wo
ich jetzt irgendwie drauf drücken damit
ich hier nicht irgendwie was falsches
drücke mit diesen scheiß handschuhen
alter ich weiß nicht ob es richtig
gesehen habe aber ich glaube dass wir
vorne typ drin ist beziehungsweise drin
war weil hier fehlt auf jeden fall eine
wand hier fehlt dafür ist er doch einer
drin
alter kommt ziel doch luca das ist doch
nicht wahr wie dumm zielt er denn heck
ist der gott das war so ca der
beschissene zweikampf den ich je hatte
aber erst mal denn mein name ist ja mal
eine pumpgun ich weiß nicht wieso denn
nicht auf die pampige switches oder
sogar wahrscheinlich nochmal anfänger
genauso wie ich bewege mich hier die
ganze zeit am rand von der mep her aber
wir brauchen auf jeden fall erstmal
bisschen holz sammeln ich kann eh nicht
bauen wenn ich diese scheiß handschuhe
an hp klawe bett grad wird das schönste
was in meinem leben passieren kann da
ich in wohnwagen von worldwide weil ich
dass diese handschuhe
die geben wir doch einen herzinfarkt
können wir noch mal hier kurz eben alles
abgrasen ob da eventuell jemand etwas
vergessen hat die tür steht auf jeden
fall offen ich weiß allerdings nicht
ohne gott der sid aus widersprechende
koffer von kika hallöchen ich sehe
irgendwie meine maus reagiert auch
einfach mal gar nicht liga ich komme auf
keine tasten da kommen dann kann sie
jetzt ein bisschen hier rumtanzen bei
der letzten challenge habe ich ja so
gemacht dass ich keine waffen benutzt
habe und dann halt irgendwie gewinnen
musste ich hab's bei baseball hat nicht
geschafft und er meinte halt einige dass
es mit der challenge alt das dass diese
falsch ist in der handschuhe aber hat
einige drunter kommentiert von wegen hey
das gab's schon bei einigen anderen und
deswegen habe ich mir etwas raus
versucht mit den handschuhen ich glaube
dass das noch niemand gemacht hat also
ich habe zumindest kein krasses video
dazu irgendwie eine art gefunden was ist
das da oben seht ihr das da oben wir
können da oben ja mal eben kurz
hinlaufen und schauen was uns da vorne
erwartet weil er war halt irgendwas nach
vorne sieht es schon wieder eingeblendet
irgendwas was da vorne und wirklich so
ein bisschen am leuchten war ich weiß
nicht genau was das ist
ein chicken nuggets ich weiß wirklich
nicht was das teil jetzt hier irgendwie
bedeutet oder was ich damit jetzt
gemacht habe das ist auf jeden fall mein
logo was ich angegeben habe aber gut wir
laufen wir hier wieder weiter runter
aber um aufs thema livestreams
zurückzukommen es gibt viele leute die
stream dann irgendwie bridge und machen
dann das mit diesem harmoniert mich
auftritts sondern kriege ich geld und
dann mache ich dies und das
für mich ist es gar nicht mal primär
irgendwie als einnahmequelle ich bin ja
relativ offen gegenüber sagt ich mache
ich würde sie jetzt gar nicht mal so
unbedingt als einnahmequelle sehen ich
weiß auch ehrlich gesagt nicht wie man
werbung schaltet bei streams sondern für
mich wer ist einfach mal so ein bisschen
was neues also ich habe schon oft gesagt
dass ich eher so ein typ bin der ein
video gerne aufnimmt eine stunde und
dann drei stunden schneidet und dann hab
ich was womit ich zufrieden bin und das
ist ein gesamtkonstrukt und das kann ich
irgendwie hochladen allerdings werden
live streams denke ich mal so ein
bisschen was neues also ich könnte live
mit euch über ihnen welche themen
sprechen
ihr könnt mir live dabei zuschauen wie
ich irgendwas mache es is life habe ich
das überhaupt schon erwähnt also es hat
auf jeden fall auch ein paar vorteile
gegenüber diesem videos und ich finde
das ist für uns alle vielleicht ein ganz
coole neue erfahrung vor allem für mich
ich denke ihr habt schon mal live
streams geschaut bevor ich jetzt nicht
so eine neue erfahrung also schreibt mir
dazu gerne eure meinung unten in die
kommentare und dann können wir schauen
ob ich dann eventuell bald meinen ersten
youtube live stream machen werde also
ich hätte das auch auf youtube machen
und ich irgendwie auf twitter oder
irgendwas anderem aber nun widmen wir
uns wieder unserer challenge aber ich
habe gerade irgendwo schüsse gehört die
kam glaube ich von da du [ __ ] sieht
schöner aus
muss man sagen also mit dem fluss
und da hinten dass das zeichen lonely
lodge schon schön kann ich eigentlich
hier baden gehen vor neid bei mir ist so
spannend oh mein gott freunde wir haben
eine pumpgun da nehmen wir erst mal hier
den ganzen kram es mit den steinen
hier haben leute gezeltet kann nicht da
kann ich in das zelt rein was stinkt
hier so kann ich die zelte kaputt machen
von den leuten ja okay kann ich sogar
kaputtmachen um mein gott freundin eine
munitionskiste da haben wir sachen für
diese verschwisterten handschuhe vorne
im häuschen haben wir hier eventuell
noch etwas näher aber nur ein bettchen
und noch eine kleine kiste hallo hallo
das mädchen kommt auf die haben doch mal
ein bisschen munition war für den
raketenwerfer denen ich natürlich auch
so toll habe es leben noch 17 leute das
ist für meine verhältnisse gar nicht mal
so schlecht die runde mit gewinnen jedes
spiel ja die sind gut darin ich weiß
nicht ob hier links in dem gebäude
jemand drin
oh mein gott zu einer schießt einer
schießt hilfe weiß was mache ich ich
kann nicht bauen
doch ich kann bauen nein ich komme nicht
auf die taste hey läuft doch hier
hochladen
wo bist du wo warst du standest du wo
bist du hier habe ich abgeschlossen mein
gott kommt von rechts lebens airbus der
bin ich tot
also ja ich bin um das braucht jetzt
nicht beantworten ich weiß nicht wo ich
ihn laufen soll hält weil man eingehen
will ich jetzt ganz ganz nah oben einer
vielleicht ja da sind schönste seht ihr
die david darauf gefeuert das heißt der
typ schild da vorne irgendwie das heißt
nicht oft da definitiv nicht hin wisst
ihr was jetzt mein plan ist ich will
mich in diesem trio hallo was wir denn
hier alles ich warte jetzt einfach hier
ich habe hier unten bubi bomber
ausgewählt das heißt wenn einer sich
traut hier hinzugehen schmeiße ich die
boogie bombe dann transfer und dann
knalle ich den ab mit meiner waffe drei
wochen später
es leben mittlerweile nur noch sieben
leute ich will doch noch in meinem lkw
aber freunde da kann man sich natürlich
auch mal über die wichtigen dinge im
leben unterhalten und zwar wie findet
ihr mainz kind kann nicht erst mal hier
ein bisschen rum auch mein gott hören
dass gegner
also da hinten ist keiner hier vorne
läuft auch keiner langen das heißt sich
wieder zurück auf die boogie bombe stell
dich mal wieder hin
ich würde ganz gerne mal rausschauen
gibt sich irgend so ein bug dass man so
ausschauen kann oder sony hier
funktioniert das nicht vorne
funktioniert auch nicht doof dann
erwarten wir jetzt einfach mal noch ein
bisschen 2000 jahre später bei euch so
wat gerade in der schule ja schön ich
spiele vorne beziehungsweise ich warte
in fortnight es leben noch sechs leute
übrigens und ich bin in der zone freunde
mir wird das ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen
zu langweilig drin ich meine wir wollen
natürlich auch ein bisschen action haben
ich würde jetzt mal schauen wo er sich
eventuell ein paar leute ich kann immer
noch nicht um die ecke hier oben gucken
ich gehe jetzt mal einfach hier raus mal
schauen ob wir hier irgendwo ein paar
leute sehen
die werden wahrscheinlich alle in ihren
komischen bases drin sein dass die vorne
vielleicht jemand hier oder hier
hallo sind irgendwo menschen gehen wir
jetzt hier vorne in seine welt rein da
werde ich auf jeden fall schon mal da
war akut verkämpft dich mit deinen cup
fallen da ich habe hier ehrenhaft
gespielt mit meinen handschuhen außerdem
ist das stylishe ganz viel besser als
dein dover skin an der stelle wird das
sind jetzt allerdings auch wenn meine
damen und herren wenn euch diese
vorteile channels gefallen hat und
eventuell bock auf livestreams zunächst
hat last man like da schreibt wir uns in
die kommentare eventuelle weitere
challenge und jetzt kommt das freunde
worauf jeder denkt ich beim anschauen
dieses videos die ganze zeit gewartet
hat und zwar das auto endlich das was
ihr ziel vom bio das was jetzt hier
video hier können jetzt jemanden kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
aus checken jetzt findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnent seid
könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken dann
bekommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]